what is it  stay here please  [Music]  guess i should have knocked  oh my god  what are you doing here disappointing my  kids  i'm supposed to go water skiing  cab needs our help come on  clint  you should not be here  really  i retire for what like five minutes and  it all goes to [ __ ] please consider the  consequences of your actions okay  they're considered  okay we gotta go  it's this way  i've caused enough problems  you gotta help me wand  [ __ ] you wanna mope you can go to high  school you wanna make amends you get off  your ass  [Music]  i knew it should have stretched  [Music]  clint you can't overpower me  i know i can't  but she can't  vision  that's enough let him go  i'm leaving i can't let you  i'm sorry  if you do this  they will never stop being afraid of you  i can't control their fear  only my own  [Music]  oh  come on  we got one more stop  you